[Music]
lionel is with us in midland texas hi
lionel how are you
good good how about you randy show
better than we deserve sir how can we
help awesome awesome i had a
uh financial question um i'm 31 years
old and i was considering uh opening my
own business i'm thinking about a
laundromat i just wanted to you know ask
y'all to see if it was the right timing
uh or something like that
why a laundromat
uh because it's a passive income um
i know the beginning of the of the
business i'm sure first couple years i'm
gonna have to be
really uh
it's gonna take up my the majority of my
time but after a little while you know i
wanna
uh
live a free life you know for for uh
you know
i don't want to be too tight up
yeah
uh you're not you're gonna hate this
because you've been lied to
it's not a passive income
uh the stupid washing machines break and
somebody has to fix them somebody's got
to go down there and get the quarters
somebody's got to manage the change
machine somebody's got to make sure the
place isn't being thieved all the time
correct so it is actually running a
business it's not a passive income a
passive income is you sit and money
comes into your mailbox this is not a
passive income
yes sir so um if you want to work at it
you can probably make some money the
laundromats are they make good money do
you have the money to buy one and set it
all up
um
i'm thinking of i'm not going to use my
personal money i would want to
ask for
loans uh and uh do it with that i have
projected i turned some numbers down and
it would take
roughly about two hundred thousand uh to
start one from uh from scratch okay
well i i can tell you what i would do i
wouldn't do it
and here's what here's why
eighty percent of small businesses fail
in the first five years in north america
according according to the small
business administration
the ones that fail 80 of them
say the number one reason for their
failure
is cash flow problems
now let me define where cash flow
problems come from from having counseled
small business people now
for
uh about two decades
cash flow problems are not paying your
taxes properly and getting behind with
the irs
not paying your sales taxes properly and
getting behind with the state department
of revenue
and having to pay payments on 200 000
worth of washing machines with quarters
that's going to kill you
okay you're you've increased the risk of
failure
a hundredfold when you start talking
about borrowing 200 000 to open a
laundromat
uh and the numbers that you've crunched
i can tell you from having run
businesses for 30 years the numbers that
i crunch are normally wrong
on a brand new venture we don't know
what we don't know
and you're not going to be your
estimates aren't going to be that close
and the rule of thumb is this
it's going to take twice as long as you
think cost twice as much as you think
and it's gonna and you're not the
exception these are the three rules
and so uh no i would never go 200 000 in
debt to open a laundromat in any economy
ever
because your risk of bankruptcy is very
very high
please don't do this
please save your money start a business
of some kind for cash out of your garage
start small make some profit reinvest
make some more profit reinvest grow your
business gradually but no you should not
go 200 000 in debt and think this
laundromat is going to run itself you've
done made two sets of assumptions here
that are both going to cause you to walk
into a nightmare i'm begging you not to
do this i think i know where this is
coming from dave because i've seen these
videos on tick tock and they're all
these entrepreneurial types saying hey
you should start a vending machine
business on a laundromat business and
here's how easy the money is stuff has
popped back it's pop back up dave but
it's on tick though so it's on tick tock
so it's cool exactly it's cool to be
stupid yes and so i think that i think
lionel's got a good heart i love that he
has an entrepreneurial spirit but he has
been lied to from the videos he's seen
about how easy it is to make this money
and some of the most heartbreaking stuff
has been around forever i know man i saw
that same stuff i was 20 years old 40
years ago
let me tell you what happened to me 40
years ago i almost bought i was gonna
pay cash but i almost bought
you couldn't die a car wash no no i
almost bought a hundred of those
uh
air compressors that you put at the
market and put a quarter in to get you
pay for air
oh at the gas station when they very
first came out i was there when they
very first came out and i almost bought
100 of them and put them out
and uh i got sidetracked doing real
estate deals and and left that to the
side but this was the same crap yeah it
was coming it was all get rich quick
stuff of income you got to be an
entrepreneur entrepreneurs are where all
the money is and all this stuff instead
of what a real entrepreneur does which
actually invents something or actually
grow a business but yeah and i really
just never could quite get past the
humor of paying for air
and that's the other reason i didn't do
it um and yet i have put quarter in one
of those things and aired up a tire
timer too
but um
like someone became a millionaire after
a quarter like i think four times in my
life i did that probably but yeah
it's uh but yeah vending machines let me
ask you let me just tell you i
know people who own vending machine
routes
that actually do it they don't have a
tick tock account i can promise you that
uh it's freaking hard work yeah and a
lot of those machines produce almost zip
and then you got to move them and find
another location for them and then you
got to move them again and then people
kick them in and tear them up
and man it's just it's
nothing is as easy as it sounds and
certainly nothing is as easy as it
sounds with stupid butt tick-tock but
then no one's going to buy my online
course as to how you can start this
passive income business with your
laundromat it's not passive at all
when someone says passive income and you
have to work at it by definition it's
not passive george oh my god well some
of the most heartbreaking calls we get
are the ones where they started a
business they took out a whole bunch of
money and loans and then the business
failed and now they have the heartbreak
on top of the business not failing they
now still owe 200 000 yeah paying
payments on your failure that'll piss
you off twice a day yeah
that's heartbreaking so don't do this
move at the speed of cash check out all
of our resources that the entree
leadership team has get off a tick tock
business advice
lord jesus
unbelievable i mean this is cats chasing
lasers and i'm glad you didn't have tick
tock when you were younger dave because
you would have started about a thousand
business i would have fallen for every
one of those things i almost bought the
air machines i really did do that i'm
that dumb
i am that you could have been an air
machine mogul by now but instead you're
running this little business wow missed
opportunity there you go that's what
happens changing lives when you don't
when you know
one one quarter one flat tire at a time
that's right won't pump you up
man wow
oh wow let me tell you meeting the
people that come to our entree
leadership events i had nothing
i knew i mean i know there's a get rich
thing happening out there right now a
vibe
happening especially among your
20-somethings and you guys you guys
think it's like the first time that this
stuff has come up that's what's so funny
vending machines are the new thing
all the old trends come back around but
you know with fashion with business it's
all coming back dave if you thought it
died let me tell you so yeah so
apparently the
so the catchphrase for get rich quick is
passive income that's it
ding ding i'll buy your online course
i've redefined the term improperly to
mean easy money
you can make money easy money you don't
have to work for a living that's right
that's what that's what that's that's
what you americans dream that's what
tick tockers mean by passive income i am
learning so much today i'm here to
educate and inspire no people the real
definition of passive income is an
actual investment that just sends you a
check and you don't have to go down to
get the quarters out of the air pump oh
my god this is the ramsey show